[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: I'm Dan
Galpin, here at GDD Europe
2017 for the Developer
Show, with Clare Bayley.
Now, she's the
global Codelabs lead
for Google Developer Relations.
Tell us about these Codelabs.
CLARE BAYLEY: Well,
Codelabs, the thing
you have to understand is that
they are the hands-on learning
component for all
of Google's content.
So these labs were chosen
to specifically accompany
all of the sessions that
are happening here at GDD.
They're a great way
for people on-site
to get inspired about something
and then go try it out.
And they're also a really
good way for people
at home, or even
after the conference,
to go and try something
out for themselves,
because there's no better
way to learn something
than to actually do it.
DAN GALPIN: What's the most
gratifying part about working
on this whole Codelab project?
CLARE BAYLEY: Seeing people
who come up at other events
and tell me that they learned
something from a Codelab
that they used.
Or having people come up at
an event and tell me they
learned something
that blew their mind.
That's also really gratifying.
DAN GALPIN: And if
you want to find out
more about all the great
Codelabs that we've had here,
you can go to this
fabulous URL and try them
all out for yourself.
There's some amazing,
amazing stuff to learn.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: Tell us about PWAs
and what's going on with that.
SAM DUTTON: OK, two
things with PWAs.
I think we're getting these
great new capabilities
on the web.
The combination of that
with the reach of the web,
the low friction for users,
is really, really powerful.
And with that, we're seeing
these beautiful experiences,
stuff like Twitter Live,
which is fantastic.
Incredible sites.
And these really, really
small install sizes.
DAN GALPIN: So where do you
see the future of all this
at the moment?
SAM DUTTON: Well, OK.
Some favorites of mine.
I love the stuff that's to
do with media and images.
So we've got a bunch
of really great media
APIs coming to the web.
And then stuff
like image capture,
for taking photographs and
controlling camera hard drives.
It's like that tight integration
with the platform, the device,
the operating system.
I love it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: I'm here
with Sara Robinson,
and Sara is a
developer advocate who
works with big data and machine
learning on Google Cloud
platform.
What is your favorite of
their pre-trained APIs?
SARA ROBINSON: My
favorite would have
to be the Video Intelligence
API, which is actually
our newest of the
machine learning APIs.
And what you can do with
that is you pass it a video,
and it gives you
granular data on what's
happening in each scene
of your video along with,
at a high level, it tells
you what the video is about.
SARAH CLARK: We did
a search of 10,000
jobs for senior and
intermediate-level developers
and analyzed them to figure
out all the core skills
that the market's
looking for, and there
were some surprises in there.
DAN GALPIN: What are the
kinds of skills that you get?
Give me some examples
of the kinds of skills
you would learn in order
to get the certification.
SARAH CLARK: So a
lot of developers
tend to ignore accessibility,
but that turned out
to be very important.
A lot of fundamental skills,
actually, are in there, too,
because most of the hiring
managers these days are saying,
well, I want you to
work without jQuery
or other supporting libraries.
And so developers really had
to build a strong foundation
to do that.
But we do go all the way up
into progressive web apps.
DAN GALPIN: I hear that
there are some scholarships
that students can
get here in Europe.
Tell me a little
bit more about that.
SARAH CLARK: So
Udacity is really
60,000 scholarships for
Europe, 30,000 for Android,
30,000 for Web, and
the best way to get
that is to go to our website and
look at the certification page,
and we'll have the link
and the details there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIELLE OSLER: People imagine
that tech and public policy
are kind of separate, and
public policy doesn't really
necessarily
influence technology.
But policy makers are thinking
about this all the time.
So we wanted to let them
know about, for example,
the evolution of the
internet of things
and that space, and also
about Android fragmentation
and how policy
makers are thinking
about that around the world.
DAN GALPIN: Tell me about the
policy issues that are going
around the Internet of Things.
I mean, I don't even feel like
there is any policy around it.
Do you--
DANIELLE OSLER: Well, it's
one of those spaces that
is really quickly evolving.
And this is particularly
a good place
for developers to engage because
the space moves so fast that we
don't think that law will be
telling developers what they
should do, but
that developers are
going to be setting the norms
that policymakers will follow.
And then what can we do
for security, generally?
How do we think about
security, and what
should be put in place for
the plethora of IoT devices
that we don't even know where
they're going to go yet?
And how do we think
about security
if there are so many
different diverse devices that
are out there?
[MUSIC PLAYING]